have you noticed that ever since it
became clear that republicans will very
likely retake congress in the fall
our old pal
dr fauci
has toned down all of his political
demands the man who locked us all down
for two years
has just disappeared
he's stopped appearing on tv
he's announced that he plans to retire
by the time biden leaves office
and now
now he is denying that he ever even did
all the stuff that he did
during covid
there were
authorities that made different
decisions than the cdc's recommendations
for example on school closures and they
did not see higher levels of child
mortality when it comes to covet and
meanwhile the schools that did close
down we're now seeing just disastrous
levels of learning loss among poor
children children of color mental health
crisis i wonder if you would recommend
locking down schools if you had to do it
all over again
well you know again it's first of all i
didn't recommend locking anything down
you you're asking me questions you're
talking about the cdc is the public
health agency that uses their
epidemiologist and their science-based
approach to make recommendations locking
down what are you hold on me you talking
good old dr fouch you think i would ever
want to oh come on that's the craziest
thing i ever heard you think that i
the beloved dr fauci would ever have
spent two full years trying to lock down
the entire country that's you're crazy
lady so
he seems so sincere he seems so earnest
in his denial i thought maybe
maybe i'm misremembering it i just i
have this distinct memory of dr anthony
fauci
recommending repeatedly that we lock
down the entire country
when it became clear that when we had
um
community spread
in the country with a few cases of
community spread this was way before
there was a major explosion like we saw
in the northeastern corridor driven by
new york city metropolitan area
i recommended to the president that we
shut the country down
and that was very difficult decision
because i knew it would have serious
economic consequences which it did
oh okay all right because that that clip
we just listened to that was from a
couple of years ago the clip we listened
to before that that was just from a
couple of days ago
and fauci just completely changed his
story but we heard it we have the tapes
we have we have our memories but we
actually have him on film he says i
recommended to the president that we
shut down the country even though it
would have very terrible economic
consequences which it did he's even
admitting that it did so what happened
did dr fauci just forget that
i thought he was such a smart guy he's
got all those fancy degrees he's such a
genius he's so responsible
did fauci just forget his advice did he
forget
the pandemic and did he forget his
decisive role in the last two years of
american life
i don't think so i i think the answer is
a lot simpler than that i think dr
fauci's political machinations all the
things he says start to make a lot more
sense once you understand that the man
is simply a liar
he just lies
he lies with ease
for 40 years he has lied with impunity
and when republicans retake the congress
they need to make this little napoleon
in the lab coat answer for every one of
those lies and every one of those
misdirections that have led to so much
misery for so many people for more than
two years now i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from mozzarella who
says michael if bestiality is wrong then
why isn't it called wurstiality you make
such a great point i really never
thought of it that way but you're right
shouldn't it be called worst reality
what's the deal with that
you guys hear about that tip your
waitress
you know when i think of of services
that are the absolute best in their
class you know right first thing comes
to mind rock auto right now go to
rockauto.com enter knowles in there how
did you hear about us box do you ever
get frustrated when a salesman tries to
sell you a product that he knows
absolutely nothing about usually just
because it's the most expensive thing
you go to a restaurant you say what kind
of wine do you recommend they always
point to the most expensive wine on the
menu you go into any kind of stories oh
what kind of shoes should i buy they say
buy the most expensive shoes right even
though they're not the right shoes for
you drives me crazy this is one of the
things i love about rockauto.com these
guys are not trying to push the shiniest
or the most expensive product or the
product with the most marketing behind
it they sell auto parts because it's
what they know and they sell the ones
that work for you and there's no hidden
agenda here they're not trying to push
this one part over the other you go on
to rockauto.com they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
you go they've got a super easy to
navigate website you find exactly the
part you need for the make the model of
your car or truck same prices for pros
and do-it-yourselfers no gimmicks go to
rockauto.com get the brake shocks carpet
wipers headlights mirrors mufflers lug
nuts or any other part you need
rockauto.com and then be sure to write
knowles in their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
dr fauci is looking a little nervous
i'm not saying i see beads of sweat but
he's acting a little more nervous than
he usually does dr fauci is usually
so extremely confident
now
now he's
pulling away from the cameras which very
difficult thing for fouchy to do most
dangerous place in washington is between
fouchy and a tv camera now he's saying i
will retire at the end of biden's term
now he's saying look i've got nothing to
hide if rand paul
and all those republicans in the senate
want to investigate me fine
your reaction to rand paul and others
saying they're going to investigate you
if they take power
well there's there's no reason to do
that but if they want to go ahead my
records are an open book
they are talking about things that are
really bizarre john like crimes against
democracy by shutting down the
government all i have ever done and go
back and look at everything i've ever
done was to recommend common sense good
cdc recommended public health policies
that have saved millions of lives if you
want to investigate for me for that go
ahead
okay sounds good i think we'll do that
then listen here i've never done
anything wrong oh good then that the
investigation should go just fine right
except
i seem to recall well i seem to recall
that five seconds ago you lied about
your role in the lockdown so that's not
good i seem to recall at the very
beginning of the pandemic you lied you
explicitly lied about your opinion of
the efficacy of the face masks you said
face masks don't work i'm only slightly
paraphrasing face masks don't work don't
wear a face mask especially in the early
days of a pandemic when it's spreading
like wildfire doesn't do anything it's
not going to stop you from getting it
five seconds later he says okay actually
they work i just didn't want to tell you
that because i wanted to save the masks
for my friends in public health i did
not want i thought people would buy up
all the masks and then my friends
wouldn't get them but now my friends got
them and so i can tell you the truth
about my opinion which is that they do
work where ten of them
and on and on and i'm just using that
one example it's probably the most
infamous one
there are countless examples of this not
just fauci getting something wrong he
should be investigated for that too but
it's worse what i find much more
offensive than fauci getting things
wrong consistently throughout not just
the last two years really throughout his
40-year career of corruption and
incompetence we did an entire
docu-series here at the daily wire on
this i presented it fauci unmasked you
can get it if you remember right now
daily wire plus
it what i find much more offensive about
him getting things wrong is that he he
lies so much
he and he lies effortlessly and that is
very offensive especially to a
self-governing people
people that are supposed to be free and
able to govern themselves when this
bureaucrat who's been in power for 40
years here presidents come and go the
elected officials come and go dr fauci
remains he outlasted trump he's going to
outlast all of them
it's very offensive when this guy is
unresponsive
to the people and it's very offensive
when he repeatedly lies to the people so
all right good rand paul wants to
investigate fauci i want to investigate
fauci
a lot of republicans want to investigate
a faction and fatchi says fine
investigate me good make it happen guys
okay i don't want this to be an empty
threat he's trying to run away from the
investigation he actually said that
those were his own words he said well
you know if i again i'm only slightly
paraphrasing if i retire they're
probably not going to investigate me
quite as much so i should get out of the
job he actually said that in print
he knows that an investigation won't
turn out very well for him he needs to
be held to account
for his lies for the way he
inflicted so much misery on the american
people for two years for his role in
funding the wuhan laboratory where the
virus almost certainly came from for so
many frankly even for
for mishaps outside of covid years
before kovit when he was mishandling
aids when he was mishandling
various vaccines and epidemics that were
cropping up in the 2000s and the 20
teens okay
all of that stuff this guy needs to be
held to account don't go squishy
republicans don't just make this they do
this they do this sometimes don't just
make this a campaign slogan and you get
the votes and then oh well never mind
vouchers out of the picture don't do
that hold the guy to account
he probably will be out of the picture
pretty soon if he's going to leave
when joe biden leaves because joe biden
does not look like he's long for this
presidency joe biden doesn't look like
he's long for this world joe biden just
gave an update last night he was giving
an update on january 6th and trying to
ramp up his attacks about the
republicans and trump in january 6th
the guy gave a zombified press
conference
that that made you think
the man is not well
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-cop you can't be pro-insurrection
and pro-democracy you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-american donald
trump lacked the courage to act
the brave women and men in blue all
across this nation should never forget
that
so forget for a second that his voice is
just completely different than it
normally is it's he sounds like he
sounds like joe biden doing one of those
anonymous interviews that gangsters do
regardless smashing up the voice he's
got the voice is all crazy
but then the weirdest part of the the
interview
or the press conference rather
is that he doesn't blink
that whole talk he doesn't blink once
his eyes are super wide puper's pupils
dilated they're obviously
pumping this guy up with something
he's got more energy than he's ever had
in a kind of weird stilted robotic way
he wouldn't be the first democrat
president to be injected with uppers in
the white house john f kennedy famously
had that happen to him from dr feelgood
and it stands to reason that joe biden
would need this too joe biden was
already 21 years old when president
kennedy was having this happen to him
the man is obviously past his prime he's
obviously
not in control of himself much less the
country and it does raise the question
who is calling the shots here
speaking of drugs
there's been a big debate over puberty
blockers and cross-sex hormones and all
sorts of weird transgender drugs not
just for adults but for little tiny kids
puberty blockers kids can go on those at
eight years old
okay and there's been a big debate over
this and the white house the biden white
house where the assistant secretary of
health is a man who thinks that he's a
woman
who is very very in favor of injecting
little tiny kids with these sorts of
drugs and the left-wing establishment
in its entirety has gotten behind this
transing the kids campaign and then the
conservatives said hey
hold up
i think maybe it's not a great idea to
inject tiny little kids with a bunch of
chemicals to make them look more like
the opposite sex maybe we should hold
off on this a little bit until we
there's no way even if you buy into
transgenderism there's no way that this
can really be good for the kids and the
libs said we're anti-science and we're
crazy and we're bigots and we're phobic
and we're this and we're that so the fda
earlier this month just added a warning
to puberty blockers specifically to
gonadotropin
releasing hormone agonists
gnrh but that's that's what we're
talking about when we talk about puberty
blockers
the warning indicates the risks for the
little tiny kids who take these drugs
the fda identified six cases in females
between the ages of 5 and 12 who were
taking these puberty blockers
which presented quote a plausible
association between gnrh agonist use and
pseudotumor cerebri
what are pseudo
tumor cerebri that's also known as
idiopathic intracranial hypertension it
this means that your brain swells up
that's what's happening when we inject
these little kids with the puberty
blockers in enough cases that the fda
now has to add a warning label kids uh
skull
the pressure entire inside kids skulls
spontaneously increases this causes
brain swelling severe headaches nausea
double vision and permanent vision loss
this according to the mayo clinic this
according to the fda this is what we're
doing when richard levine gets up there
in his little skirt with his long hair
and he says for my equality so that i
can feel really good about my delusions
we need to pump little tiny confused
kids full of drugs that are going to
make their brains swell and make them go
blind to say nothing of the other
problems that these drugs cause because
when they get a little bit older and
they go on the cross-sex hormones those
drugs are causing osteoporosis they're
causing they're causing young otherwise
would be healthy people to become
crippled all to justify the delusions of
these sick grown men who should be in
counseling if not outright
institutionalized and instead what we've
done
is put them in charge of health in our
country can you imagine how sick that is
can you imagine of course you can
imagine it we're living through it right
now
these are the geniuses
these are the public health people these
are the people running our country doing
this
and they say trust the science and they
say trust the fouchy and they say trust
the richard levine i don't have trust
for any of these people if an african
witch doctor and shaman walked in here
with a headdress and a big cauldron full
of
bones and bats and
double double toil and trouble or
whatever they've got that dates back
five thousand years i would trust that
man's medical opinion much more than i
would trust the medical opinion of dr
richard levine or dr fauci and i think a
lot of people are waking up to that fact
right now if if a political regime
would do this one they're not to be
trusted when it comes to their faculties
of reason they don't know true from
falls
but two it's just so freaking evil it's
so evil to do this to little kids all to
justify the delusions of
mentally ill or sexually perverted grown
men it's just so
so wrong you feel it in your bones you
feel it so
deeply
and everyone knew this everyone knew
even for some of the people who
maybe
don't have medical degrees which i guess
is most of us you don't need a medical
degree to know that pumping kids full of
these chemicals is not good for them
okay and now all of a sudden the white
lab coats are catching up well actually
maybe this is maybe it isn't so good to
pump little tiny kids full of all these
drugs well we're going to keep doing it
anyway because they disregard the
science and they disregard the
philosophy and they disregard the
natural law and they just pursue their
own
radical delusions
speaking of grooming we have a we have a
grooming update from the new york times
just when you think the grooming has
reached the maximum amplitude they turn
the grooming up to 11 headline in the
new york times the books about sex that
every family should read that's going to
be the title of my next blank book
the books about sex that every family
should read a comprehensive guide and
it's going to be 250 blank pages maybe i
won't be able to use that exact title
because the new york times wrote a
serious earnest article listing these
books the books
are listed here and described by elaine
blair
elaine blair let's just let's just cut
right back to the biography
is a
los angeles-based critic and an
inaugural winner of some prize for
literary criticism
a left-wing writer
describes him or herself as trans mask
all sorts of things it's kind of like on
twitter when you see somebody's pronouns
in the bio you know that that person is
deluded and is going to say really crazy
things so what are the books that we
have to read about sex to our kids
just i'll just open right from the top
of the article about eight years ago
when my daughter was in preschool i went
to the children's alcove of our local
library and found the book that i'd
heard was the standard bearer of liberal
sex education
for younger school-aged children it's so
amazing a book about eggs sperm
birth babies and families
this is when this person's daughter was
in preschool
so i gotta go get the book on
on sperm and eggs and sex for my
preschooler
it's so amazing covered many subjects
anatomy gender fertilization gestation
birth love heterosexual intercourse
sexual orientation child sex abuse and
hiv you've got to tell your preschooler
about hiv what if your preschooler wants
to go to a gay bath house certainly your
preschooler needs to know the risks of
hiv right you've got to what three year
old doesn't need to know about this
in a chapter called what sex an
unclothed man and woman partly covered
by a blue blanket kissed in missionary
position when two people care for each
other sexual intercourse is very loving
i read in the accompanying text
but but so at this point we should
obviously take the book burn it
chase the author out of town on a rail
ban this from the libraries for
three-year-olds should obviously not be
reading this but
this author in the new york times her
problem with the with the book
is that the book was not radical enough
because
it says then came the next chapter
what's love with pictures of smiling
families and couples in many different
configurations watching tv eating meals
cuddling walking dogs with nearby text
explaining the meaning of words like
straight gay and lesbian now something
nagged at me
all of the different kinds of couples
did fun things together with their
clothes on
but only the man and the woman in the
previous chapter got to take their
clothes off hold this book this book on
sex for my three-year-old it only shows
a man and a a woman
having sex it doesn't show two dudes or
two chicks or three chicks and a goat
and it doesn't you know it does it does
it certainly doesn't go far enough for
my toddler this book's well-meaning
attempted inclusivity practically
spelled out a hierarchy of value
heterosex is sex
true
the other stuff is very loving
though very loving is off-brand so then
that was the that was the bad book that
one wasn't radical enough according to
the new york times so now they're
promoting this other book this other
book is by someone named corey
silverberg
and they include a picture of corey
silverberg
and if you if i told you right now close
your eyes
and picture the kind of grown man who
writes books about sex for little tiny
kids i said just picture
and then you opened your eyes you would
see
the image from your mind
he's a grown man he's got kind of a
weird haircut he's got a kind of creepy
smile
he's got his eyes are looking up his
hand is resting his head is resting
playfully on his hand a little
he's wearing a bright green shirt kind
of groomy shirt he's got some of his
nails painted
and he spends his time
writing
books about sex
for little kids why does he do this
why does he do this he says
it's corey silverberg he's written sex
is a funny word
what makes a baby you know sex
and they've upended the genre silverberg
who uses they pronouns is skeptical of
the term sex positive and would like to
see a world with no
normative pressures
around sex
no
normative pressures
around sex what is a normative pressure
around sex it means rules
it means do this don't do that that
a normative pressure around sex might be
it's better to get married
and
not have sex with lots of people and
just get married and remain in a
monogamous marriage and maybe even be
open to the possibility of that would be
a normative
pressure around sex here's another
normative pressure don't have sex with
little kids
that's a normative pressure around sex
that's saying this is good this is bad
don't do the bad thing do the good thing
that's but we don't
this guy silverberg he's imagining a
world where there are no normative
here's a normative pressure around sex
don't have sex with animals
that's that's a normative pressure no
but we we want a world man where it's
going to be so nice when there's no
normative pressures and then we're all
doing things that are completely
degenerate and i think i know exactly
why these people
why
the million-dollar question
why do these people
have to push this stuff on little kids i
think i know the answer first though
is it ironic to make an ad for an
ad-free viewing experience it might be
but that's exactly the type of
experience you will get when you
subscribe to daily wire plus this is our
growing hub for all things daily wire
where you will find shows podcasts like
like this podcast
movies bonus content and coming soon
kids content
not the kids content you read about in
the new york times okay not the kids
content that disney's trying to foist on
us right now
good wholesome appropriate kids content
daily wire plus is everything you love
about daily wire plus so much more and
minus the ads go to dailywireplus.com
become a member today get 35 off your
new membership that's dailywireplus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
the new york times is pushing really
creepy sex books on little kids little
kids like preschool little kids
and the new york times is complaining
that these books aren't explicit enough
the books where they show men and women
having sex for three-year-olds but they
don't show two dudes having sex that's
not explicit enough even this really
creepy guy corey silverberg who's
writing these kids sex books and who
says there should be no normative
pressures around sex and who thinks that
he's multiple people and he uses the
they pronoun the new york times is
saying no even he this guy's positively
wholesome compared to the kind of books
that we want we want graphic photos we
are not photos at least illustrations we
want extremely vivid descriptions of
really really creepy perverted sex stuff
for not even just
15 year olds that would be bad enough
not even just eight-year-olds that'd be
really really bad for three-year-olds
for preschool
why
why are these people pushing this stuff
on little kids i think i have an answer
i think
i think the reason and this is i i
imagine a sincere belief of theirs
they think
that everybody just needs to be
degenerate these people are so
degenerate
they are so divorced from any
good standard of living
that they think
that nobody could possibly even aspire
to that good standard of living that
everyone else has to be degenerate too
i'm really not
speaking from the position of being
holier than now or sanctimonious or
saying i never make mistakes i've never
sinned far from it
i'm speaking from the position of
having a standard
that you think is good and that you try
to live up to and that with some work
and prayer and humility and the grace of
god especially the grace of god you
actually can
approach to some degree
you actually can live a more virtuous
life
if you practice the virtues and if you
pray and if you
if you pursue a relationship with god
and you allow god's grace into your life
you
that actually can happen
and i think a lot of people today just
don't think that can happen
because we are mired in a culture that
incentivizes and encourages perpetual
vice in a way that wasn't true
even 30 years ago
it's hard for us to imagine because
there's always vice in society there are
always drugs there's always crime
there's always prostitutes there's
always there's always vice everywhere
but there is a difference in degree
even just when we're talking about the
creepy sex stuff that the times is
pushing the very fact that we are now
swimming in a culture of extremely
hardcore pornography and it's just
because people have cell phones and
computers that wasn't true 30 years ago
even just that
is going to change the way that people
view
the possibility of anything even
resembling virtuous living i remember a
friend of mine
some years ago
good pal of mine he was going through a
little bit of a wilder phase in his life
and he was getting a little a little
wild okay let's just leave it at that
and we were talking about it one time
and i was like i don't know pal you
really want to keep doing this do you
think he really is this really fun is
this really fulfilling and he said well
you know look it is fun it is very fun
but one thing that i miss
is innocence
he said i miss
i do miss innocence everything now is
kind of jaded and cynical and
people know this
if you get into drugs if you go boozing
too much if you sleep around too much if
you
if you're just slothful if you if you
engage in any of the vices enough
you get really jaded and the world just
doesn't look as beautiful as it once did
you kind of miss
innocence
and the craziest part of that is most
people believe once you lose innocence
you can't get it back
you actually can that is and
people don't really believe it until
until you see it or experience it but
you actually can that's that's what
repentance
does
repentance which is just it just means
changing your mind kind of going in
another direction
when you seek absolution when you seek
forgiveness for your sins when you
try to do better every day at a time
talk to any alcoholic who is in that
bottom pits of despair and then let's
say they've been in aaa for 20 years
they've been clean for a couple of
decades now they will be more innocent
they will be more wholesome they will
find joys and pleasure in things that
are more virtuous and good and innocent
and they don't just need to go down to
the bar and you know find their only
pleasure at the bottom of a bottle you
actually can regain that kind of stuff
but i think these these perverts and
these degenerates who are at the new
york times and who are writing sex books
for kids and who are trying to apply
kids with cross-sex hormones and mess up
kids and all this way i think they they
genuinely don't know that they don't
know that there is another option or
they don't believe it even if they do
know that or they don't think that
there's any way for them to improve
their self themselves there actually is
though
and it's it's not even just up to them
it's not even just to pull yourself up
by your bootstraps this needs to be
encouraged by the state i can't tell you
you know getting back to the porn thing
i get
letters
constantly from young men who say i i'm
hooked on porn
and it's really hard
yeah that's that's a you that's a you
problem but it's also a political
problem
our country until very very recently we
still have the laws on the books
severely limited porn because they know
that when porn is
widespread and available people are
going to be more likely to to use it and
when people are more likely to use it
it's going to make them a lot worse and
it's going to be really bad for them and
it's going to make their lives a lot
worse and it's going to make the country
a lot worse too and it's going to make
the country less and less able to govern
itself it's not just true of porn this
is why we have laws against certain
drugs it's because with certain drugs if
they're ubiquitous if they're all around
everywhere then it's going to be hard to
resist using them it's going to make the
country a lot worse this gets back to an
essay it was written by el brent bozell
jr
back in 1962 when the post-war
conservative movement was really coming
into shape brent bozell was william f
buckley jr's brother-in-law and friend
from college bill buckley
broadly credited with creating the
post-war conservative movement and it
was a debate on the the central issue
that was going on at the time which was
the fusion of the libertarians and the
traditional conservatives
and some people like frank meyer at
national review were encouraging this
fusion and said it made a lot of sense
other people the traditionalists like
brent bozell like russell kirk some
other people were saying i don't think
this is really going to work because
we've got a fundamental
disagreement here the libertarians
believe that the be all and end all of
society is freedom
in their kind of narrow understanding of
it the the maximizing your choice at any
given time
and the traditional conservatives think
that the be all and end all of society
is virtue the good life a flourishing
society
so the conservatives love freedom but
they love freedom as an instrument as a
means to an end freedom in its proper
place can help a society prefer
pursue virtue
when we talk about the blessings of
liberty that the founding fathers wrote
about they're viewing liberty in that
way they're saying liberty is good but
what we're really after is the blessings
of liberty
the human flourishing the virtue the
liberty is just a means to an end
that's a fundamental disagreement and
sometimes you'll hear the libertarians
say well we care about virtue too we
care about the good life too but virtue
if it is not totally freely chosen
is not virtuous at all
so you can't have any
any incentives to have live a virtuous
life
if if we ban most porn then it's not
virtuous if you don't look at porn
it's only virtuous if we've if you have
the temptation and you resist it
okay but if we follow that idea to its
logical end
then the most
virtuous society should be the one that
just floods every everything with porn
right if we follow that idea to its end
then the most virtuous society will be
the one where we've got heroin
everywhere on the street and and it's
being offered to you maybe it's even
being subsidized oh my goodness how
virtuous would you be if you were
offered free heroin and you said no to
it
the most virtuous society would be the
one where every marriage has uh you know
outside of every marital home has a line
of hookers being sent by the state
because if you resist the hookers then
oh my gosh you're the most virtuous guy
in the world right it's absurd it's an
argument that that when taken to its
logical conclusion you can see the
absurdity of it which is what brent
bozell does in that famous essay freedom
or virtue
i think
we we let the
maximizing individual choice people run
the show for a long time on the left and
even
leading the conservative movement
and it's led us to a very bad place
where we're transiting the kids where
we're doing all sorts of terrible things
and where we're now promoting porn for
preschoolers
maybe it's time to try a different
course
ev everything that the conservatives the
traditional conservatives predicted at
the beginning of this little experiment
in brent bozzell's essay everything they
predicted has come true
everything the right-wingers predict
this country you know you hear about the
slippery slope
well
if we change the definition of marriage
pretty soon
we're going to be changing the
definition of sex and then all the
liberals say no that's not true that's
great you're a crazy conservative that's
not what are you talking about well it
all happened it's all been happening
the normalization of pedophilia it's
happening it's all happening
we've got to try a different course
freedom is a great thing we love freedom
but we need to view freedom as the
founding fathers did as the great
americans have
as having a point what's the point of
freedom it's not just so that i can
shoot up heroin gosh wasn't that great i
made the free choice to shoot up heroin
i made the free choice to cheat on my
wife i made the free choice to rob my
neighbor no that's not good the thing
that's the thing that freedom is for is
so you can make the right choice so you
can do the right thing and by the way
even when there are when there are
limitations on your freedom let's say
the state bans certain drugs or porn or
whatever
certain even behaviors that you still
have freedom you still have moral
freedom
moral freedom cannot be taken if moral
freedom is real it cannot be taken away
from you
by the state or by anybody else
now speaking of absolute quack public
health nonsense have you heard about
abortion doulas have you heard about
doulas doulas are this kind of new
hippy-dippy way
to uh help women who are giving birth
so it's a kind of
um
a woman who just she isn't a medical
doctor necessarily but she knows a lot
about giving birth and she helps women
through the process of giving birth and
i'm actually pretty pro doula i think
it's a good service especially because
i'm so skeptical of the medical
establishment
now there's something called an abortion
doula anna dace just discovered this she
took a little course on how to become an
abortion
doula and it's it's the opposite of a
doula right you're helping a woman to
not to deliver her baby and bring new
life into the world to but to actually
kill her baby and in this training anna
dace came across a great confession from
the libs and from these pro-abortion
people take a listen a fetus the medical
definition is like the tissue of a
pregnancy that um grows past eight weeks
gestational age um before that it is
considered an embryo
a baby or child using that sort of
language um
contains connotations of personhood um
so when i talk about abortion i um talk
about pregnancy tissue
um
it's not wrong for somebody to use the
words baby or child when they're talking
about a pregnancy um but
like you don't necessarily want to be
using language that your client might be
uncomfortable with always important to
like mirror your clients language and
check in of course we'll talk more about
that later
it's not wrong
to use the words baby or child
i just don't use them
i call it pregnancy tissue right before
i go and kill the baby or child sorry i
mean pregnancy tissue that's an amazing
confession
what she is saying is yeah we use these
euphemisms
reproductive health embryo fetus tissue
because we don't want to admit the
reality that i will privately admit to
you right now of course it's a baby
of course it's a baby but
we don't want to admit that so we just
changed the word same way that the biden
administration right now doesn't want to
admit that they're in a recession so
they just changed the words we're not in
a recession
the libs are so hyper focused on this
kamala harris who thinks she's running
for president kamala harris vice
president of the united states just came
out she said we've got a really big
problem in this country really really
big problem no it's not the economy no
it's not immigration no it's not the war
in ukraine no no the really big problem
is women are getting pregnant
to put it in law
there may be litigation but we will be
in a much better position
than um than to not do that and you know
listen
women are getting pregnant every day in
america and this is a real issue and we
need to act with a sense of haste
about what is at play what is at stake
and codifying role will be an important
moment in terms of
putting back in place protections
for for the folks who are at risk right
now because of what the court did in
dobbs just weeks ago
this is a real issue getting pregnant
and these women are really at risk
they're at risk of having a family
they're at risk of being happy they are
at risk of having a good flourishing
traditional
marriage and family and community and
society they're at risk and we democrats
we're going to do everything we can to
stop that from happening
just got some great news in my ear this
is the most important political news of
the day
we just hit 1 million subscribers on
youtube thank you to everybody who did
that i assume
the the youtube the google battalion is
about to fly over my building bomb my
studio that's it they're not gonna let
me get even one million and one thank
you though sincerely to all of you who
have subscribed made the channel so big
it's amazing to think that just that one
million subscribers that's just on
youtube that's not not counting facebook
or the podcast or apple podcast or
spotify or the daily wire website
obviously so we're really really so
pleased when this company started in
jeremy's pool house five or six years
ago we did not anticipate it becoming
this big so thank you that's really
really thanks to all of you
i you i guess you know who i am
because you subscribe and you listen to
this show that's so great in case you
don't know who kamala harris is here she
is to introduce herself
good afternoon i want to welcome these
leaders for coming in to have this very
important discussion
um about some of the most pressing
issues of our time
um
i am kamala harris my pronouns are she
and her i'm a woman sitting at the table
wearing a blue suit
[Laughter]
i i i think i know why kamala harris is
doing this but it just reads it's so sad
it just reads that the vice president of
the united states is like a
four-year-old a five-year-old showing up
to her first day kindergarten hi i'm
kamala i i like the color blue and i'm
wearing a jacket uh
but people call me cammy okay uh what's
next yeah we know you're the vice
president you don't need to tell us what
shirt you're wearing
you don't we know that your pronouns are
she and her because you're a woman we
know that
we can move on
how about we talk about like china
aggressing in the south china sea and on
taiwan how about we talk about the
russian pipeline to europe that caused
the invasion of ukraine how about we
talk about inflation how about we talk
about the the federal reserve system if
we talk about anything more complicated
then go look at my colors and look at my
genitals
huh not doing i'm not doing
a comment impression by the way that's a
young child impression i'm gonna i'll
work on my kamala impression she has to
do this
you know she has to do this a lot of
people are making fun of her they're
saying what are you doing kamala has to
do this because kamala has to be the
woke candidate if she's going to run in
2024 and i know it's not a natural fit i
don't think kamala harris is the most
left-wing person in the democratic party
i don't think kamala harris really
believes much of anything she didn't get
her political career because she was so
ideologically radical or ideologically
precise and such an activist she got her
political career for lots of reasons
that it would be untoward to discuss on
this show but she is a
let's just say a smoke-filled room kind
of politician okay she's not a
uh
a woman of the people who goes out there
and she's really popular and she's got a
popular agenda and she no she doesn't
she was the first person out of the
democratic primary in 2020 but she's got
to be the woke candidate
because she's only the vice president
because she's a woman who is vaguely
brown
that's why that's what biden said biden
said i'm only going to pick a black
woman and kamala sort of checked those
boxes and the only other options were
susan rice who was the fall man for
benghazi for obama and
karen bass who was who was an actual
communist in congress those were the
only three choices that were even being
considered and so by process of
elimination you get kamala harris but
because kamala is the black woman
identity politics candidate she's got to
play the race game she's got to play the
sex game
she's got to play the woke game
that's the only argument for her
candidacy
and it's it is as awkward as it seemed
in that meeting
and the other the other candidate who's
playing this game who is clearly trying
to shiv kamala harris every single day
on television that would be pete
budajudge who is doing better than she
is
pete buddha judge transportation
secretary when he's not on maternity
leave pete but a judge
is doing so well
relative to joe biden
he actually just beat biden in a new
hampshire poll there was a poll
done by university of new hampshire
for the 2024 presidential race
and
buddha judge beat biden by one point
again this is sort of damning with faint
praise because biden is so deeply
unpopular right now and buddha judge
actually did relatively quite well
compared to joe biden in new hampshire
in the last presidential election but it
just shows you how weak biden is shows
you how weak really the entire field is
the democrat prospects no matter who the
nominee is are not
great especially right now we're waiting
on these these inflation numbers
especially right now or i'm sorry we're
waiting on the
gdp numbers
because the white house is preemptively
redefining recession so that every
newspaper in america doesn't read the
headline america is in a recession so
this happened on television a couple of
days ago now the national economic
council director brian dees goes right
up there at the white house and he
explains how a recession is not really a
recession
on the uh the definition of recession
which has been an issue that i know many
of you have reported on
um
as secretary ellen said on sunday
two negative quarters of gdp growth is
not uh the technical definition of
recession it's not the definition that
economists have traditionally
relied on
yes it is
yes it is
usually when politicians make some
declarative statement like that
you say well there's a little bit of a
half-truth here and i guess there's a
kind of you could kind of argue what
you're saying but here
no the answer is no you're just
lying you're just wrong that is the
textbook definition of a recession
two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth is a recession
open up your dictionary right now you
can even go on google they i don't think
they've changed the google definition
yet that is the definition of a
recession this is the same thing they
did with vaccines you remember this i
don't i haven't seen anyone else make
this connection but it just shows you
it's their it's their modus operandi
with the vaccines they said but what's a
vaccine a vaccine stops you from
contracting or spreading a virus
and they said specifically with covet
these vaccines you take the vaccine you
won't catch covid you won't spread covid
and then the vaccines didn't do that and
the vaccines didn't function like normal
vaccines and so what did they say three
months later they said no no no the
vaccines they just stop you from going
to the hospital no no the vaccines they
just may they'll just mitigate your risk
of death vaccines were never supposed to
stop you from catching the virus
vaccines were never supposed to stop you
from spreading the virus no you all said
that they would do that fauchi walensky
biden you all said they would do that
and then they didn't do that and so
rather than admit that you were wrong
rather than try to fix the problem with
the vaccines you just changed the
definition you're just changing the
definition
of everything you're just you're just
lying
and you're hoping that through the
transformative power of your words you
can change reality and that's not going
to happen i don't think that's going to
sell with voters i don't think that's
what the polls show and when the people
put the better representatives in charge
in november
i want to see
endless investigations and then at the
end of those investigations
at the end of those endless
investigations once they're really
exhausted i want to see
consequences for the people who have
lied to our faces and disrespected the
american people and made our lives
significantly more miserable for two
years i want
justice i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show merrick
garland reportedly looks at criminally
charging donald trump tama harris
announces her pronouns and the imf
predicts global recession that's today
on the bench bureau show give it a
listen